many actors are willing to transform
themselves for roles from gaining and
losing weight to wearing prosthetics and
more
but for some actors taking on the
ultimate film role
means going to extremes sometimes even
permanently hurting their bodies in the
process
here are some actors who've earned some
serious albeit sometimes invisible scars
for their art jared leto in chapter 27
as we've come to know very well at this
point jared leto is a method actor
who doesn't hold back when it comes to
transforming his body he's lost
major weight for films such as requiem
for a dream and his oscar-winning turn
in dallas buyers club but it was
actually gaining weight for the 2007
indie film chapter 27 that really did a
number on the actor
playing mark chapman the man who shot
and killed john lennon
and leto admitted he gained so much
weight so abruptly that he suffered
gout letter revealed that the weight
gain hurt his body so much
towards the end he couldn't even walk he
told the los angeles times
i had a definite problem with my feet
towards the end of the shoot one of the
glaring issues was the pain i had with
my feet
i couldn't walk for long distances i had
a wheelchair because it was so
painful my body was in shock from the
amount of weight i gained
it took about a year to get back to a
place that felt semi-normal
and i don't know if i'll ever be back to
the place i was physically
hey at least dying his hair green and
putting in metal teeth to play the joker
and suicide squad left
no indelible marks well except for
ronnie's career
i'm just gonna hurt you really
really bad tom hanks in philadelphia and
castaway the affable tom hanks isn't
necessarily known to be one of those
actors who loses himself in roles
but he has gone to a view extremes here
and there and has won two oscars for his
efforts
in both the 1993 drama philadelphia in
which he plays a lawyer
diagnosed with aids and the 2000
survival pick
castaway hanks had to lose a lot of
weight during the shoot
thanks to the forced fluctuation and his
own genetics of course
the actor revealed that he was later
diagnosed with type
2 diabetes he said that he probably
won't be taking on
any more roles which require him to
drastically change his size
as a result of these experiences george
clooney in syriana
while george clooney didn't have to
undergo much of a physical
transformation for his oscar-winning
role in 2005's
siriana he still experienced a real
headache during the making of the movie
while filming a torture scene for the
political thriller the actor cracked his
head open during a stunt and severely
injured his spine he told rolling stone
at the time the pain from his injury was
so bad he considered taking his
own life i was at a point where i
thought
i can't exist like this i can't actually
live
i was lying in a hospital bed with an iv
in my arm
unable to move having these headaches
where it feels like you're having a
stroke
and for a short three week period i
started to think
i may have to do something drastic about
this doctors couldn't quite pinpoint
where the injury was
at first they clearly weren't as good as
his er alter ego
doug ross but finally noticed fluid
leaking from clooney's spine
and realized that the condition was more
serious than anyone had thought the
actor revealed to the hollywood reporter
that he was
forced to take strong pain medication as
part of a long process
and eventually turned to pain management
for help dealing with his chronic
discomfort
but he'll never again be a hundred
percent
i've gone from where i can't function to
i've got a bad headache my ears will
literally pop and my head goes
ape but i'm scrappy
because i think i've crossed a line
sylvester stallone
the expendables three as a longtime
action movie star sylvester stallone
knows a thing or two about cuts
bruises broken bones the whole shebang
in fact he had once joked that he grades
the quality of movies by how badly he
got hurt making them
so suffice it to say he certainly
experienced
more than his fair share of pain on the
set of movies including a permanent
injury on the set of the expendables 3
in which he reprised his role as
mercenary barney ross
the action star suffered a nasty fall on
the set
that left him in need of spinal surgery
but believe it or not stallone's
injuries weren't even the scariest from
that film set
co-star jason statham almost lost his
life during production
while he was driving a truck on a
loading dock the brakes failed and the
truck plunged
60 feet into the black sea thankfully
statham who competed on britain's
national diving squad for 12 years
was able to get free and swim to safety
and here you thought those shoot em up
bang bang blockbusters were all just
pretend
linda hamilton in terminator 2 judgement
day linda hamilton's badass turner sarah
connor in 1991's terminator 2
set a precedent for female action stars
to follow
she took the role very seriously
training her tail off to play the
hardcore mother of the leader of the
future world
but for all the fight sequences and
stunt work it's hard to bounce back when
a shotgun blast goes off near your ear
while shooting the scene in which shera
is trying to escape the psych ward and
has to reluctantly accept help
from the new and improved terminator the
actress forgot to put her earplugs back
in
after a take when schwarzenegger led off
a round in the elevator
trying to stop the t-1000 the amplified
sound caused hamilton
permanent hearing loss of course
hamilton wasn't the first action star to
get hurt from gun shooting blanks
bruce willis in die hard that's right
the same type of injury also befell the
man who played john mcclane while he was
making his action thriller breakthrough
die hard according to the actor after
firing off a fateful round
he suffered two-thirds partial hearing
loss in his left ear
he added that now he has the tendency to
say what
his daughter rumor willis even said the
reason her dad isn't as talkative while
promoting a movie
is because he sometimes struggles to
hear the questions
huh that explains a lot or does it
i dreamed i was on a boat michelle yo
encroaching tiger hidden dragon it comes
no
surprise that michelle yeoh injured
herself during the spectacular
scratching tiger hidden dragon with all
the incredible stunt choreography
involved there had to be a misstep
i think in life you must make a choice
either you do it or you don't
indeed at one point during the filming
yo landed wrong and her knee gave out
sure enough the action star completely
tore an acl in her knee
yo had to have surgery and months of
physical therapy
and while she was able to recover she
admitted you never get all the way back
to what it was
angelina jolie insult angelina jolie is
another star who never does any of her
action movies half-assed especially
her 2010 spy thriller salt jolie played
a cia
officer accused of being a russian spy
who must prove her innocence
while on the run to prep for fight
scenes jolie had to learn a combination
of muay thai
and krav maga which she did during two
hour sessions
three to four times a week some of her
stunts included jumping off a highway
underpass onto a moving truck
but amazingly that wasn't the scene that
literally scarred her for life
speaking at comic-con at the time she
said it happened during a scene which
involved her rolling onto the floor
and left her with a permanent scar her
stunt trainer simon crane told
us weekly during her final fight with
liev shriver
she had to dive through an opening door
firing a gun
as she carried the sequence on she
rushed into a corner piece of a set
and bumped her head the injury left a
permanent mark or
so they say not that anyone can tell
daniel
craig inspector british actor daniel
craig's time playing james bond has left
him with his fair share of injuries
as the stunts became more elaborate with
each film
in casino royale two of his teeth were
accidentally knocked out during his
first stunt
and had to be capped and in quantum of
solace he suffered several
injuries there was a blow to his face
that required plastic surgery
and he was rushed to hospital after
slicing off the top of his finger
he also tore a muscle in his shoulder
and suffered
badly bruised ribs but it was craig's
time on spectre
that did some permanent damage while
filming a fight scene with the hulking
villain mr hinks
he injured his knee it required surgery
and threatened to halt filming
for six months but craig didn't want to
wait and put off the surgery
working through the pain he told empire
this has been a two year process
since we began talking about the script
it gets to the point
and you say we can shut down for six
months and you can go have surgery and
come back
then i was like that i don't give a
stick two planks of wood on it and i'll
[ __ ] crack on
and crack on he did and in the end
production was stopped for only two
weeks
craig has since had a few surgeries to
repair his knee and has joked he'll only
keep playing
double 07 as long as his knees hold out
jackie chan in basically all of his
movies
kung fu legend jackie chan has never
held back and views
any injury he sustains while filming a
stunt as just part of the gig
it's one of the reasons chan is
considered a true hero
of the martial arts genre i hear the
crap from
i look at my feet upside down oh
then then the camera man are you okay i
said
i'm okay did you get the shot he's
broken fingers his nose
ankles his tailbone even his hip he's
dislocated his shoulders more than a few
times
and suffered multiple concussions and
spinal injuries
the injury list is as long as his resume
however there's one particularly serious
booboo that made a lasting impression
on his banged up body during the shoot
for armor of god
he was supposed to do what was a simple
stunt jump
but he was so hurt by the maneuver that
he had to have
brain surgery which included the
permanent implantation
of the metal plate even so chan's moving
momentum and commitment to doing his
own stunt work has never wavered chan's
the champ
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too